my name is Ryan hi I'm Kat and we're
gonna watch the trailer for a movie
right now
that I don't remember the name you do
not know what we mean it I totally
forgot what oh wait it's not gonna be a
movie right now it's gonna be a movie
review no wonder I didn't remember it's
gonna be of my favorite movie critic out
there Jeremy Johnson sent me you might
know and you know what cat has never
seen Jeremy Jones yet haven't I'm sure
you guys have if you're into a movie
review channel you must have seen Jeremy
Johnson yeah the guy's hilarious we're
gonna have a lego movie review that's on
energy and want to be in it I wanted to
be in it I love Lego they just did it
without me well I invited you like all
the time and you wouldn't movie whatever
man but yeah I wanted her back on
because let's face it she's a little bit
better looking than I am nothing to do
with your person your personality does
not matter at all at this point yeah I
don't mean that please don't hot girl
gets upset it really affects my emotions
a lot of hot girl gets yeah yeah a
regular girl you don't you don't care
about who gives a [ __ ] well then alright
guys this is random reactions by the way
it's a new playlist and yeah it's so we
can just react to anything really we can
react to it is gonna be a lot of random
[ __ ] because why just watch trailers
let's let's get this show on the road
you know Jeremy John's review through
the lego movie makes me feel less stupid
because I have like those when I was
like a baby like we need to be more
animated miss Jeremy John's opening
yeah the lego movie so I go Moo
situation about a lego world in this
Michael world dude he's a lego guy he's
a comic guy he's got some special
LaMotta me boy finds a thing in this
thing means another thing ultimately
this common Lego guy gets wrapped up in
this adventure and then we see a bunch
of Legos and pop-culture references
among the Lego world that's all cool it
really is one of the things that drives
this movie first of all I like the
animation animation made it feel like
it's actually laid head so trigger that
zoomed in on these tiny ass Lego people
you're watching their thoughts
who else build things like they're real
Legos which just now I realize I just
said that Lego people build Legos movies
done with Legos you have an explosion
happening somebody blows up the
explosion the fire the smoke all done
with life back you're like I guess you
really can create everything with Legos
I've seen some crazy [ __ ] I ever seen
their movie built around Legos that's
just really impressive even if it was
done on the computer and a movie having
all these different worlds that allots
them a lot of opportunities make
pop-culture references but it makes the
movie feel a little broken up people in
the shows you feel like the rotaries
showcase a lot of different lego worlds
but in that the movie feels like you
could have had one lego world completely
reconciling that movie now not too long
which I get for a Lego these are endless
you want to show it all you got to be
careful they make the movie too long
movie I was like I don't know where this
movie's going really the beginning
didn't really land with me so far from
the movie then after that the movie
starts making me chuckle and that they
change something happen you may be the
man who goes that is awesome that's just
awesome we're talking really awesome
doesn't be who know me when you watch
the movie you're gonna be like that's
the moment Jeremy was talking about and
you will be right so ice enjoyable as
all this stuff is in the movie I was
watching I was like enjoyable movies
then the last 15 20 minutes of the movie
happens and I was like all right now
I got the guy who wrote Toy Story 3 they
were like can you please write this he
was like not a problem friends and I
don't even have to be credited with it
now we have the end of this movie I
stuff really in hitch you were you late
but just hit true yes it does I wish she
knew he was on we're not in January
anymore new any other movie month of the
year for happening finally so in the end
the lego movie was enjoyable it was a
little long-winded in times I'm not all
of the joke slang to watch it really
unstable then the really relatable jokes
for us older kids were man children
lands and the end happens and you walked
out of the movie and you're like I can't
say it wasn't great
damn Legos do the thing ya required but
it just it's like a wine it starts
getting better as it ages and by ages I
mean I watched the movie like different
generations of Legos they're different
Legos used to be you just had a bunch of
blocks and they were like you want to
make something will make something make
something of that and it makes something
of your own that want to make a Lego
Star Destroyer everything comes in the
box specifically to make a Lego Star
Destroyer has to be sounding old bag
around a Legos for tough I would make a
cube it's like here here's a Lego cute I
made it with four blocks from here right
so the lego movie have you seen it what
did you think about it I'm always your
favorite Lego set growing up or now
shoot Legos are huge now if you have a
favorite now no one can fault you for it
whatever answer to any of the questions
might be comment below let me know do
you want to see more like right here to
see more you watch him for you
I watched him a lot he's awesome I think
he's really cool yes yeah yeah I can see
why people love him because he's just
he's so personable you're still in the
frame he's cute too you think he's cute
I don't know if I'm in the frame I guess
we'll find out I mean no no good it's
much better when it's just me but yeah
Jeremy Jones here's my answer for you I
really liked the lego movie it's a
really want to say one of my top 10
favorite movies did that review make you
want to see it more
see that's what you did Jeremy you
inspired her and my favorite Lego set
would have to be it's one of the Star
Wars once I don't know how to describe
it but I really enjoyed it did you have
one my favorite um no I just had like
this
a little house actually and there are
these little Lego girls that lived in
the house and yeah I guess they go girls
yeah they made like us four girls to you
they were people was it uh where they
attractive were they like Barbies and
Ken's no they were just like the Lego
boys but with longer oh that sucks I
mean just some people they might be
considered here did you play with
Barbies yeah that's right he started my
directing I would tell my sister snake
your girl go this way and they're like
and then this is what she says and I
would direct the whole plane the play
yeah you called it a play yeah I would
make a little play and I would be the
director and the two of us would have
actors that were the Barbies and I would
tell them what to do no wonder she still
probably hates me I love you Jenny I
miss you sorry I was so bossy when we
played Barbies I don't know you are
Jenny but Held's Jenny Jenny mmm she's
in her 20s like me
well my name is Ryan J Danny's married
and has been well Jen looks like I'm
gonna cause problems